la parole est à notre collègue robert
del picchia pour les groupes union pour
un mouvement populaire vous avez la
parole vous chers collègues bien madame
la présidente
mais n'est ce pas là messieurs mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresser au
ministre des affaires étrangères elle
s'adresse toujours d'ailleurs mais je
comprends qu'il ne puisse y répondre car
si je suis bien informé il accompagne le
président de la république en chine bien
alors l'explosion de cette voiture
piégée à tripoli dont on parle depuis
trois jours soulève un certain nombre de
questions ici à paris mais aussi mes
chers collègues de graves inquiétudes
pour nos compatriotes du réseau
diplomatique et au delà de nos
communautés françaises à l'étranger
alors certes le ministre laurent fabius
a annoncé à tripoli de l'envoi d'une
équipe du gign entre temps les sur place
d'ailleurs il a également annoncé le
renforcement de la sécurité des intérêts
au moyen-orient et dans le sahel ces
annonces sont bien sûr les bienvenus
mais sont-elles suffisantes soyons clair
mes chers collègues nous le savons tous
il y à des menaces d'al-qaïda contre la
france
al qaïda au maghreb islamique aqmi a
directement menacé vendredi dernier la
france de représailles pour son
intervention au mali alors la question
paraît légitime mes chers collègues cet
attentat n'était il pas la mise à
exécution de cette menace et surtout
est-ce que l'on avait bien pris toutes
les mesures de précaution
en septembre dernier
en septembre dernier l'ambassadeur
américain christopher stevens et trois
autres ressortissants américains ont été
tués à benghazi
à la suite de cet attentat
le gouvernement libyen avait promis de
mettre sur pied une force spéciale de
protection des diplomates or apparemment
on ne voit me dit on que de rares
voitures de police libyenne qui
patrouillent de temps en temps
alors nous savons mes chers collègues
que le pouvoir libyen éprouve toujours
on le sait les plus grandes difficultés
à imposer son autorité sur un pays où
d'importantes quantités d'armes sont
toujours en circulation et où de
nombreuses ministres agissent à leur
guise alors étant intervenu auprès des
autorités libyennes pour plus de
sécurité pour nos compatriotes à
l'avenir de plus en plus inquiet on peut
les comprendre mais au delà de la
sécurité de nos compatriotes et les
implications politiques en libye et sur
toute la région cet attentat est aussi
un signal très inquiétant car c'est un
élément dissuasif supplémentaires pour
les entreprises déjà réticente à les
travailler en libye et dans d'autres
pays autour le vice-premier ministre
libyen avoir un bar asie a déclaré et je
le cite nous sommes dans une période
cruciale et certains veulent
déstabiliser la libye mais cette fois
les auteurs de l'attentât ont touché
deux cibles à la fois la libye et la
france alors on voit mal aujourd'hui
dans ce contexte de violence et de
risques extrêmes le développement des
relations franco libyennes alors comment
peut-on les envisager nous sommes
toutefois tous ici d'accord ici à paris
mais aussi permis nos communautés sur le
terrain à l'étranger pour réaffirmer
avec force qu'il ne faut jamais jamais
cédé aux terroristes
et permettez moi au nom des français de
l'étranger madame la ministre de rendre
hommage ici
ont glissé à tripoli et au delà à tous
les membres de nos services de sécurité
qui font quotidiennement acte de courage
au service de nos compatriotes à travers
le monde merci de votre attention
la parole est à madame hélène conway
mouret ministre chargé des français de
l'étranger
merci la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur del picchia vous remercie pour
votre question qui me permet d'abord de
confirmer que la sécurité de nos
ressortissants français à l'étranger
qu'une priorité vraiment un axe
prioritaire pour le ministère des
affaires étrangères et que c'est une
question que nous traitons avec sérénité
et responsabilité
laurent fabius en effet est parti
immédiatement à tripoli après l'annnonce
de l'attentât pour apporter son soutien
et celui du gouvernement aux deux
gendarmes blessés dont un grièvement et
qui ont été depuis rapatrié en france le
ministre s'est rendu sur place pour
exprimer notre solidarité à nos agents
consulaires qui font un travail
remarquable ainsi qu'à notre communauté
française petit certes près de 300
personnes pour prendre les mesures
nécessaires afin de renforcer leur
sécurité ces français participent à la
reconstruction de la libye et qui
promeuvent nos intérêts mais aussi nos
valeurs et nous devons les protéger les
mesures de sécurité étaient déjà très
importante et je peux en témoigner les
décisions immédiates ont été prises pour
les renforcer encore les différentes
implantations françaises telles l'école
l'institut le service et la mission
économique ont été fermés un groupe de
hippies gign et vous y avez fait
référence est déployé à la résidence de
l'ambassade où se trouve rapatrier la
chancellerie il a été demandé à nos
ressortissants français aussi de ne pas
sortir en attendant de nouvelles
instructions vous savez que
quotidiennement ils reçoivent des
consignes de la part du post si la
france a été ciblé par cet acte
terroriste se sont bien aussi les
libyens qui en sont victimes plus que
jamais la france est déterminée à me
bats avec mon micro est déterminé à
accompagner la libye sur le chemin de la
stabilité
le 12 février dernier laurent fabius a
présidé une conférence au quai d'orsay
afin de mobiliser la communauté
internationale
nous avons notamment prévu de former
près de 3000 policiers libyens et
mission européenne devrait arriver sur
place en juin ces actes isolés barbares
sur le fait d'extrémistes qui bafoue les
idéaux des révolutions arabes avec les
libyens et tous les peuples qui luttent
pour leur liberté
nous y resterons fidèles cet acte n'a
pas été revendiqué plusieurs hypothèses
sont possibles celle de la
déstabilisation interne en libye comme
celle de représailles suite à l'action
de la france contre le terrorisme
notamment en libye mais sachez que nous
ne céderons jamais à la violence les
auteurs de ces actes seront retrouvés où
qu'ils se cachent ils seront jugés et
ils seront punis l' enquête a commencé à
paris et à tripoli avec la nomination
d'un juge antiterroriste
les autorités libyennes nous apportent
tous les sous tous leurs soutiens et
nous en remercions